a romantic comedy a couple days after
Valentine's Day has already happened
which makes this movie remarkably
irrelevant This Means War right so this
means war stars Chris Pine and Tom Hardy
and they're fighting over Reese
Witherspoon
the catch is they're both spies so they
spy on each other when they're out on a
date with Reese Witherspoon you know fun
stuff like that however is directed by
Mick G Mick G movies are like Red Bull
you know it has a lot of energy and just
absolutely no sustenance whatsoever now
I've seen a few other reviews on this
movie and they all say the same thing
that I absolutely agree with for the
first part of this movie you don't like
it you don't care about this movie
you're like this is bad for about the
first half an hour then after that
you're like okay this is entertaining
cuz it's what I came for all the slow
is over and now you're watching
these spies go out on dates with Reese
Witherspoon and compete with each other
that's what you came for because that's
what the trailer presented to you
however after that I hated the end and
then I kind of like the end then I hated
the end again the ratio is stronger
dislike to like in this movie however
seeing two spies fight over a chick is
just entertaining as hell I mean Chris
pints the cool playboy ladies man Tom
Hardy's actually the nice guy even
though he looks like he can break
Batman's back if everything about this
movie was when they were messing with
each other it seemed that Beastie Boy
songs
gosh I love that song and loved that
music video in the end I liked the
actors I thought they played their
characters well I like Chris Pine
however if I do I'll just see Star Trek
I like Tom Hardy however if I do I'll
just see Star Trek nemesis or warrior is
yeah who's probably a warrior in the end
I would say this means war would be okay
if you're drunk ya know as a party and
possibly getting a handy in the
background make G movie that's what
they're there for
and yes parts 1 & 2 of the you reviewers
movie awards are both up on en TV right
now so I will show you what you came
here to see hot blondes who say my name
all like hot like hey Jeremy it's fan D
from en TV I am so excited that you're
hosting the year reviewers award this
week you're gonna be amazing be sure to
subscribe to ENTV
oh you're too sweet you are in and
you're right
god bless you ma'am and your hotness and
your mind which I respect as a woman so
put annotations right here for parts 1 &
2 of the year reviewers movie awards
I'll put links below in the description
also you don't have to wait around or
anything like that don't worry they're
up right now so go check them out tell
us what you think how do you like them
in any case if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more